Transcriber: Omar Alghtme
المدقّق: Sara El shaarawy
نحن كبشر أحيانا نلجأ لقصص شخصيات
أو قصص نجاح نحب أن نسمعها
حتى نتأكد أننا طبيعيين.
أحيانا عندما نحضر قصة نجاح شخص تعطينا
تفاؤل وتحسن لنا نفسيتنا،
اليوم سأبدأ بمشهد
أود منكم أن تتخيلوه كأنكم تشاهدون فيلمًا
بما أني أعمل بالتلفزيون أحب أن أبدأ
بهذا المشهد
جود ذهبت إلى أمها يوم من الأيام
وأخبرتها:
ماما أنا أظن أنه حان الوقت
انه يجب ان أذهب لدكتور .
صارحت أمها بالموضوع، ولأن علاقتها مع أمها
كانت قوية وقريبة، وتقول لها كل شيء
وكأن أمها أختها الكبيرة، ردت عليها أمها:
إذا هذا يشعرك بالطمأنينة،
وتودي أن تذهبي للدكتور، لما لا، هيا نذهب
ربما يستطيع أن يعرف أو يبرر الذي يحدث لك
وصلنا عند الدكتور مكتوب طبيب أعصاب وكهربة
المخ دخلت عنده وكنت صغيرة بالعمر، جلست
بدأت أشرح له مشاكلي،
وأنا كنت أشرح له سألني عن شخصيتي
أنا طول عمري طالبة نشيطة
بالرياضات وبالتلفزيون
بالإعلام عندي حس تمثيلي رائع،
ليس لدي أي مشكلة مع الناس، لا أتوتر
بالعادة أمام الناس
نظر في وهو يقول:
لكن أنت بمجال التوتر فيه طبيعي جدا، أكيد
أنت لأنك متوترة دائما هذا يحدث معك،
لا عليك، لكن لا تخافي سأعطيك هذا الدواء،
خذيه بانتظام وسترين كيف أن الأمور
ستتحسن من غير أن تقولي لأحد، وأنا قلت له
أن هذا سر أنا بحياتي ما قلته لأحد
أمي وأبي وأخي لاحظوا هذا علي،
على مر السنين وأنا أكبر
كانوا يرونه ويمزحون، وكنت أنا أمزح معهم
لأني لم أكن أعرف ما مشكلتي.
كان هناك تنمر في المدرسة، ولهذا اليوم،
أنا أتذكر بعض البنات بصفي كيف كانوا
يضحكون علي، كانوا ينظروا ويؤشروا علي
ويضحكون، وأنا كنت أضحك معهم
رحلت من عند الدكتور وبدأت أستعمل الدواء
يوما بعد يوم
لاحظت أنه صار لدي بطء في الحركة وبطئ
في الاستيعاب،
أنا شخص بلعب رياضات كنت ألعب كرة قدم
وأركب خيل
أصبحت عندما أمتطي الحصان لا استطيع
رفع يدي
وإذا ركبت السيارة لا أستطيع التحكم
بعجلة القيادة
عندما أنظر للأمام بالكاد أرى
قلت في نفسي:
ما الذي تغير؟
أنا إنسانة ناجحة في العديد من الأشياء
نجاحي يزيد وإنجازاتي تكثر،
ولكن هناك شيء بداخلي متأكدة أنه غلط
ولست قادرة على معرفة ماهو
المهم، الدواء اوقف حركتي ولم يعالجني
وكذلك الدكتور
ذهبنا له مرة أخرى، ولدكتور ثاني وثالث
ورابع، لكن لم يعرف أحد مشكلتي
أنا واثقة أن هناك مشكلة
وسأقول لكم لاحقا ماهي المشكلة
كانوا يقولون لي: لا لا يوجد مشكلة،
هذا مجرد توتر من مجال التلفزيون والتوتر
من التمثيل، وبسبب أنك ممثلة فأكيد تمرين
بضغوطات
لأن طبيعة شغلي من الخامسة صباحا حتى منتصف
الليل بالتمثيل كل يوم بالمسرح كل يوم.
أنا كجود جوحان، ممثلة ومذيعة ومقدمة برامج
وإلى آخره، هذا كله ليس مهما
هذه الشخصية تتطلب أن تكون واثق من نفسك
تتطلب أن تكون حاضر دائما.
أنا كشخص بدأ بعالم المسرح والتمثيل والشعر
والإلقاء
الفنانة العظيمة “جولييت عواد” هي التي بنت
شخصيتي،
أشعر بأنها لاحظت هذا فيّ وأنا طفلة ولكنها
لم تتطرق إلى هذا الأمر إطلاقا
وبما أنها لم تنجب أطفال، كانت تقول لي أني
مثابة بنتها
وظلت تدربني وتساعدني وتقول لي:
ارفعي رأسك، ارفعي ظهرك، انتبهي لمخارج
الحروف واهتمي بالحضور
تقربي من الناس بهذه الطريقة،
افعلي هذا وذاك
ولكن، لم نتحدث في الموضوع إطلاقا
المهم،
أمسكت زمام أمري وأنهيت دراستي
في ذلك الوقت
وذهبت للجامعة، ولكن من هنا بدأت المشاكل
عندما تخرجت من المدرسة، تخرجت بأقل معدل
في تاريخ المدرسة،
ولا أعتقد أن هناك أحدا بلغ هذا المعدل،
لهذه الدرجة كان الوضع سيئا
وإلى هذا اليوم لم أقل لأي أحد كم كان معدلي
حصلت على درجات ممتازة في جميع المواد،
إلا مادة الرياضات
كنت أقول للناس أني لا أستوعب الرياضيات
بجدية، فمثلا كنت أقول واحد زائد واحد يساوي
إحدى عشر وليست إثنين
لهذه الدرجة لم أكن أستوعب شيء
كانوا يقولون: ليس ثمة
أي خطب بك، أنتي فقط لا تركزين في دراستك
والأنشطة التي تؤدينها تؤثر عليك
المدرسة واللجوء وإلى آخره، من الممكن
أنك لم تعطي الدراسة حقها
أرد عليهم:
لا لا أنا متأكدة أنه توجد مشكلة أكبر
لما ذهبت للجامعة أول مادة درستها الرياضيات
رسبت في كل امتحان رياضيات،
ثم ذهبت لدكاترة الرياضيات في بريطانيا،
لأني كنت في إنجلترا
قلت لهم:
والله يوجد مشكلة ولا أعلم ما الذي يحصل معي
ففكرت أني ربما أعاني من صعوبة القراءة
في الحروف أو الأرقام، وقلت من الممكن
أن أستعملها كحجة
قالوا لي: لا لا تعانين من أي صعوبات
في التعلم، أنتي بخير، المهم،
جود كان حلمها او طوحها ان تصبح مذيعة
مشهورة أستطيع أن أبرز الوطن العربي وبلدي
الأردن واللغة العربية لبلاد الغرب،
ودائما أرفع رأس الأردن،
وعملت هذا الشيء ببريطانيا كلما قابلت أحدا
أحدثه عن الأردن
أي شئ أريد ان أشرحه احكي عن الأردن، وأتدرب
بجهد كبير لأن طموحي كان أن أصبح مذيعة
مشهورة، وكان هناك كثير من المشاهير مثلنا،
مثل “أوبرا وينفري” وغيرها،
كنت أتابع برامجهم، ودائما أتطلع إليهم،
وأقول لنفسي في يوما من الأيام سأصبح مثلهم،
كنت أحبهم لأنهم كانوا طبيعيين وكانوا
قريبين من الناس كما تعرفون “أوبرا” تجلس
بمقابلاتها تتحدث مع الناس وتتحدث عن أمور
نحن من الممكن نستحي أن نتحدث فيها
خصوصا في مجتمعاتنا
المهم، انني بذلت جهدا كبيرا وتوظفت
رجعت إلى عمّان، وفي لندن
اشتغلت في الإعلام، ظهرت في أكبر القنوات
التلفزيونية، شاركت على سجادات حمراء
وتغطيات لأفلام ضخمة جدا، عملت مقابلات
مع مشاهير هوليوود مثل ويل سميث
وغيره، كل شيء مثالي والحياة تسير
بسلاسة
الإعلام بحالة جيدة، التمثيل ممتاز
وكنت أشارك في أشياء رائعة وكان الناس
يقولوا أن “جود” تنجز وحياتها تتطور
وعلى ما يرام وسعيدة
وأكيد حياتك مثالية لأنك على مواقع التواصل
تظهرين بشكل رائع
ولكن هناك سر، سر طول عمري مثلما ذكرت سابقا
ثلاثة أشخاص كانوا يعرفونه في البداية،
وأصبح هذا يؤثر علي
أصبت بالاكتئاب وأصبحت قلقة ولم أعد أعرف
كيف أتصرف
وأنا دائما أقول: الإعلامي الناجح
هو الإعلامي الصريح والحقيقي،
الإعلامي الذي يكون على طبيعته وأنا
من اليوم الذي دخلت فيه مجال الإعلام
أحب أن أكون على طبيعتي
حتى لما أعمل مقابلة مع شخص أحب
أن أقول له يا رجل اهدأ أنت لست مختلفا عنهم
كن طبيعيا قل ما عندك، ارتاح ولا تتوتر
ولكن أنا أصبحت أتوتر
ولم أعد كما كنت
أصبحت عندما أريد أن أمثل
أفكر كثيرا وأقلق كثيرا ولا أعرف ماذا أفعل،
أصبحت الأمور جنونية
وأهلي يعرفون ماهي مشكلتي
بدأت في التلفزيون
عندما أظهر في تلفزيون كنت أظهر شخصيتي
كان يقال لي: أحببناك اليوم، تقاريرك ممتازة
وكنت أعد هذه التقارير
كنت أعمل بالقناة لوقت طويل حتى أظهر
التقارير بأفضل صورة
خصوصا بمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي.
لماذا؟ حتى أخفي هذا السر، لأني ممثلة
ولدي القدرة على إخفاء الأسرار
لكن وصلت لمرحلة من كثرة الضغوطات
لم أعد قادرة على إخفاء هذا السر
وبالإضافة إلى هذا الكلام لأن الناس بالوسط
الفني وحتى بينكم، اصبحوا الناس
يعرفوني سواء بمتاجر أو بمحل تجاري،
لم أعد قادرة على إخفاء هذا السر.
عندما انتهي من الحلقة. اليوم التالي
يعقدوا اجتماع. نريد جود في الاجتماع
وكان هناك مذيعين ومخرجين وإلى آخره،
اتهموني بأني لم أكن أحدثهم وكنت فقط أطلع
وأتحرك أتكلم في المايك فقط،
جود اليوم غمزت للضيف!
أنا لم أغمز للضيف!
أنا متأكدة أني لم أغمز له! جود تتصرف
كما تشاء ولا ترد على أحد
وازدادت حدة المشاكل
وأصابني الاكتئاب وأنا أذهب للدكاترة
ولا أحد يقول ما خطبي
لندخل في الموضوع، من منكم اليوم لاحظ
أني حركت كتفي بطريقة غريبة؟
جميل
أنا جود أعاني من...
الآن ستعرفون ما هو
قبل ما اقول ما هو
قدمت استقالتي، لم أعد قادرة على الإكمال
في مجال الإعلام
شعرت بأن الأمور لن تسير على ما يرام
إلا عندما أكون
صريحة أمام الناس، وإذا أردت أن أكمل
وأرتاح نفسيا،  ليس باستطاعتي أن أكذب عليهم
يجب علي أن أأخذ وقتا لأضع نفسي أولا وأرتاح
لأعرف ما خطبي وبعد ذلك أكمل مسيرتي
الشيء الوحيد الذي كان يساعدني هو التلوين
دائما ألون، كنت ألون في دفاتر التلوين
الخاصة بالكبار وأحببت الفن،
أنا شخص أحب الفن كثيرا.
قررت أن أعود لبريطانيا لأخذ إجازة لمدة
أسبوع أو أسبوعين
وهناك اشتريت دفاتر تلوين وبدأت
بالتلوين
جلست على جهازي المحمول، ومن الأشياء
التي تساعدني أن أتفاءل
والتفاؤل هي صفة من الواجب علينا أن نطورها
باستمرار
أشاهد مقابلات كما قلت سابقا، “لأوبرا
وينفري” أو غيرها من الأشخاص
كنت أتصفح اليوتيوب ووجدت مقطعا
عليه ما يقارب الثلاثين مليون مشاهدة
وهو عبارة عن مقابلة للمطربة “بيلي إيليش”
مع الممثلة الكوميدية “ألين دي جينيريس”
وكان هناك أخبار عاجلة على القنوات
الإخبارية
أن “بيلي إيليش” أخيرا تصرح بمرضها
التي تسمى متلازمة “توريت”
ففتحت المقطع لأني أحب “بيلي إيليش”
وشاهدتها
وكنت جالسة لوحدي في الليل على جهازي
المحمول ومكتبئة ومتدمرة ولا أعرف ما أفعل
ولجأت للفن لأني أحبه
وأنا أشاهد بدأت بالضحك وقلت في نفسي:
هذا الذي يحدث لها هو نفسه الذي يحدث لي
وفي الغرب يكون هناك تركيز على هذه الأمور
ويتحدثون بها في كل مكان
ومقالات وأخبار عاجلة و“بيلي إيليش” تخرج
وتصرح بمرضها
وفي نفس الوقت تكلموا عن المشاهير
الذين يعانون من هذه المتلازمة
أقفلت المقطع ثم بعدها بحثت
عن هذه المتلازمة على “يوتيوب”
واكتشفت أنها تبدأ من الصغر، وأني أعاني
من هذه المتلازمة
“جود جوحان” وهي صغيرة كانت تعمل حركات
لاإرادية،
حركات تتعلق بالأعصاب وليست قادرة
على التحكم بها
لما تذهب للدكاترة كانوا يقولون لها:
هذا مجرد توتر
وكنت أرد عليهم:
لا لا كتفي يهتز ولستي قادرة على إيقافه
وكوعي وخصري يتحركان باستمرار،
وأنا أرمش بطريقة غريبة جدا
والأسوأ من هذا عندما ينبهني أحد
على هذه الحركات تزيد تلقائيا
عندما أظهر على التلفزيون ولاإراديا تزيد
الحركات
هي حركات معينة
جننت، وقلت هل من المعقول أي مصابة
بهذه المتلازمة؟
وبما أني كنت في بريطانيا ذهبت وسألت
وقلت لهم:
شخصت نفسي بهذا المرض ولكن أريد أن أتأكد
وبالفعل، أثبتوا هذا التشخيص وشخصت بإصابتي
بمتلازمة “توريت”
وهناك كثير من الشخصيات من “موزارت”
إلى “بيكهام” وكثير من الشخصيات المعروفة
وممكن هنا أشخاص بيننا مصابون
بهذه المتلازمة ولا يعلمون عنها شيئا
كانوا يقولون: جود تفعل حركات غريبة
وجود إلى آخره
كنت أعاني كثيرا، فمثلا على التلفزيون،
كنت أحاول أن أخفيها بطرق معينة
عندما أردي أ أرمش أو أفعل حركات أخرى
أعملها وكأني لا أدري
أحاول أن أتفادى الحركات بالتمثيل
بعض الأحيان أكون عند البحر بعز الصيف والحر
في أشده وتنتابني المتلازمة،
يسألوني: مابك؟ أقول لهم: أنا أشعر بالبرد
وأنا لست كذلك
يعطوني جاكيت أو بطانية ودرجة الحرارة 45
ولكن أنا لست قادرة أن أقول لهم أني أعاني
من مشكلة، أعاني من هزة لا أستطيع إيقافها
أكون ماشية وأنا أرمش بطريقة غريبة
يأتي أناس يستهزؤون بي ولا أستطيع أن أرد
عليهم، وأقول لهم لا أنا فقط لا أرى،
أنا أرى بوضوح ولكن المتلازمة عادت
بعض الأحيان، أتحدث مع شخص ما ثم تنتابني
المتلازمة ويقول لي مابك متوترة؟
وأنا لست قادرة على قول شيء، فأرد بخجل
أنا فقط أشعر بالبرد وأنا لست كذلك
أنا طول عمري بالإعلام والتمثيل، لدي ثقة
عالية
الموضوع ليس موضوع توتر، ولكن هناك شيء
لست  قادرة على التحكم به ولا أعرف ماهو!
أنا استقلت من وظيفتي وحبيت أن أنشئ شركة
هذه الشركة مختص بالفن الذي أحبه، ووددت
أن أعكس صورة إيجابية
عن الوطن العربي وكل بلاد العالم وأشاركهم
مع بعضهم البعض
صنعت دفترا للتلوين خاص بالكبار، وأنا مؤلفة
هذا الكتاب
كتبت فيه عن بلاد وحضارات العالم
وبنفس الوقت يوجد فيه تلوين،
وحبيت أني أخرج وأتحدث عن هذه الدفاتر
وكيف أنها تريح النفسية وترفع المعنويات
ورائعة للتأمل وإلى آخره.
الحمدلله لما أطلقت هذا الكتاب وكنت أعرف
ما خطبي
ولكن لم أخبر أحد ولم أقدر
أن أتحدث بالموضوع،
عندما أطلقت الكتاب
اجتاح كورونا العالم
ولحسن حظي سبحان الله نجح المشروع؛
لأن الناس كانوا في بيوتهم والكل أصبح يلون
وبعض الناس اكتئبوا في هذه الجائحة وأرادوا
أن يلونوا
والحمدلله شركتي نحجت لهذا السبب
“في قلب الصعوبات يٌخلق الإبداع”
هذه المتلازمة كانت صعوبتي طول عمري
وكثير من الناس لا يعرفون هذا الشيء
تركت عملي وكثير من الأشياء الأخرى
أُحرج أمام الناس لأن كثير منهم
كان يتنمر علي
ويقولوا لي:
ماخطبك؟ لمذا تتحركين هكذا؟
ما الذي يحدث معك؟ وكل فترة ممكن
تتغير الحركة وهناك أشخاص تحدث الممتلازمة
لديهم بدرجة أكبر
تكون أسوأ لدرجة لا يستطيعون التحكم فيها
والبعض الآخر يصدر أصوات
أنا أحيانا بعض الحركات تكون هكذا:
عندما أظهر على التلفزيون وأضطر
أعمل هذه الحركة
وأنتم تستطيعون البحث عن متلازمة “توريت”
بمجرد خروجكم من هنا
وتعرفوا كيف أنه من الصعب جدا التحكم بها
وهذا مرض لا يوجد له علاج
من الممكن أن تذهب لأطباء يساعدونك لتسترخي
وترتاح، ولكن هذا الشيء موجود
هذا الشيء كان موجودا طوال الوقت
لم يعقني إطلاقا ولم يوقفني لكي أنجح
في حياتي أو في التمثيل
مع أنه لو تبحثون عنه، ستجدون أن هذا المرض
يمنع الشخص أن
يكمل بهذا المجال وبهذا المجال وسيكون هناك
صعوبات،
وأول شيء سيأثر عليه هذا المرض هي الأرقام۔
أنت لن تستطيع أن تفهم وتستوعب الأرقام
بالشكل الصحيح
أنا قلت أني ذكية وهذا كان السبب أني كنت
سيئة في الأرقام
فاكتشفت أنه كثير من مشاكلي وخصوصا
الاكتئاب وأن يؤدي للاكتئاب
كان هذا المرض. يا ليت لو مجتمعاتنا نقدر
نتكلم في كل شيء،
نطلع عادي، من الممكن أن الآخرين لا يحبون
أن يتحدثوا في هذا الموضوع
أنا من فترة عندما اكتشفت المرض، أخبرته
لأشخاص في حياتي وقالوا لي: انتبهي
لا تخبريه لأي شخص ماذا سيفكر بك الناس؟
قلت: ليس ثمة أي خطب بي.
أنا ناجحة وذكية، طبيعية وحالتي النفسية
ممتازة بس هذه مشكلة في الأعصاب
لاحظت هذا عندما أتعرف على ناس جدد، أقابل
كثير منهم يعانون من هذه المشكلة
وبالتأكيد تذكرتم الآن أشخاص تعرفونهم
يعانون من هذه المشكلة أيضًا
في إشارات نلاحظها ولكن بعضنا لا يحب
أن يتكلم أو يخاف من هذا الشيء
وأنا مثلا بعض المرات أعمل أشياء بأصابعي
وأنا لا أدري
وعندمت لاحظت هذه الحركات كنت أسأل وكانوا
يقولون صحيح في بعض المرات تفعلين هكذا
والأسوأ، عندما أكون في النادي الرياضي أجري
على آلة الجري ومن ثم تصفق ركبي ببعضها
هذه كلها حركات تتعلق بهذه المتلازمة، لكن
فعليا أنا لست شخص ذوي إعاقة، أنا طبيعية
عندي هذه المشكلة وأقدر أن أتخطاها، طموحي
عالي وسيظل عاليا
سبحان الله بسبب هذه المتلازمة فتحت شركة
وهي ناجحة، وأنا أسير بمجال معين
وأود أن أسلط عليه الضوء وأتحدث عنه
وفي نفس الوقت...
أنا على حقيقتي وسأظل على حقيقتي
وإن شاء الله سأرجع للإعلام
في يوم من الأيام
بجود الطبيعية التي لديها المقدرة
على مواجهة الكل وأن تتحدث في هذا الموضوع
ففي النهاية, عندما يرجع الإنسان لأصله
ويعود لما كان عليه سينجح.
“من قلب الصعوبات...
يُخلق الإبداع”
وهذا كان إبداعي.
اليوم شاركت شيئا معكم لا أحد يعرفه عني
شيء كنت أُسأل عنه كثيرا
لماذا تركتي التلفزيون؟ ماهي مشاكلك؟
لماذا قللتي ظهورك؟ وأسئلة كثيرة أخرى
لفترة طويلة لم أكن أعرف ماذا أفعل
كنت أعاني ولا أواجه ولا أفضفض،
كنت أُلام وأُمنع من أشياء معينة
كنت أواجه مشاكل ولم أتحدث بها إطلاقا
ولكن في نهاية الأمر، نحن كلنا بشر
كلنا مثل بعض، ولا يوجد شيء أجمل من أن تحدث
إلى بعضنا البعض
يمكن اليوم أقدر ألهم أي شخص يسمعني،
أساعد أي شخص يريد مساعدة
أو أي شخص حتى يذهب
يلجأ لهذه المساعدة التي يحتاجها
“من قلب الصعوبات، يُخلق الإبداع”
شكرا.